well I feel a bit Canadian you know you
feel a household because my dad grew up
in Canada oh yeah he he went to Montreal
and I mean like I mean OH
like great places to go oh yeah he was
six years old so and his brother States
I have tons of cousins in Canada yeah
yeah I do
carlos bustamante et Canada
so speaking childhood I think it's like
every kid's dream to be an action hero
yeah at one point in their life right
and not only that now for you to be an
action hero but also a video game icon
so how do you feel about stepping into
that role it's amazing yeah I mean first
I grew up loving adventure films in
action film I still do
and-and-and-and and Lara Croft brought
my you know you know attention when I
was just about 19 years old I loved I've
never seen a female protagonist in a
video game and I remember how much that
meant even seeing Angelina Jolie as that
action heroine on screen and so to be
invited to be part of this and and feel
like there was truly something new and
fresh to bring out of this universe
meant a lot because I met the producers
and the director and they told me was an
origin story and I felt like this was
truly a way for you to find elements to
relate to her to feel like you're on her
jaw on on the journey with her to become
this warrior that she is and a way for
you to bring this this world to 2018
audience mmm and you really transformed
into a warrior like you look like an MMA
fighter in the movie thank you and a
lots of being said about your training
regimen but was that something that you
wanted to bring to the character
specifically because at this point it
kind of becomes character work right
turning yourself into definitely you
know i I'd love to find ways of stepping
away from myself I'm a very petite go
you know and and I loved that it was
integrated in the script that she was
this very kind of feminine woman but
with a lot of physical strength due to
the training that you see her do in the
beginning she's on the bicycle and I was
like yeah I you know if they if the
direct introduces one
action/adventure to be much more kind of
real and gritty you need to buy the fact
that she can do these things so I kind
of got inspired looking in the film
industry over the years I've seen some
amazing stunt girls and see what they
can do and I was like I need to be like
them I need to have that kind of
strength and and that will also be a way
for me to create this character that I
think I both you know admire and aspire
when I do you know to to be more like
when I read this great now four months
of intense physical training is amazing
but how much training could prepare you
for like doing all those stunt Falls
being plunged in that icy cold water
yeah no I mean that was definitely part
of of the four months of training I mean
I definitely I did put on like 10 12
pounds of muscle that my trainer helped
me but it was also about you know it's
not only about building you need to find
you know movement you need to be like
quick and and and so I did a lot of rock
climbing I traded with some incredibly
cool women both some MMA training some
boxing I did a lot of bicycling and
swimming yeah so it was so many
different elements that I that I did you
know and it all kind of came together
and worked out for this film as
inspiration you you have that look in
your eyes when you do those big Falls
like the real fear is that real is
happening I think you know that's just
that's just human you know and I love
that that was what we did in this film
you root for and you feel like you know
you're on her journey because you see
that it's tough she's she's put through
a lot of pain you know and you know
falling off a cliff for you know you
know get a big wound it's gonna hurt and
and then you had to go for it and really
try and portray the the the the real
aspect of that well it's a lot of fun
and every hope there's another one yeah
cool